i will click play and let's see what
happens i'm nervous
this game's been crashing a lot what's
going on with hulk when i was getting my
water i also ate a pickle
wow how was that
oh it's delete yeah good pickle
everything jacob says cuts off at the
end
yeah i know it was delicious
[Laughter]
all right where are we dropping boys or
is the diamond
okay wait hold on he said there's a
chest nearby dude i love a good chest
nice i'm surrounded by robots
yeah i'm here and i'm basically yeah and
big
score here we go
what are we fighting and why one
oh yeah i see the darth maul because it
also has like red lights coming off it
that's pretty cool
yeah that's pretty cool it's like your
kyber crystals are corrupted or
something nice jacob nice we
just don't talk about star wars it's
lame oh
that's some character development from
you there rahul
i just think right come on yeah that's
fair yeah let's grow up have some
decency
yeah virgins in there that's what padme
said to anakin
is this garage door breakable well it
looks like there's something inside
right there's a special
chest inside did this do it thank you
there's a giant
button giant light up button
how could we do this i don't know bad
news i think that's gonna do it
oh
oh my god we have to fight this like
metal gear solid ass spider
spider yeah i want to punch it with my
big robot arms let's do this
high five to your face you [ __ ] i got
food on my controller
um i'm not proud of it that's like the
most like gaming moment i've had in ages
it's that like there is noticeably like
crumbs from chips on my controller so
that's where i'm at in life right now i
almost never eat at my desk
cause there's nowhere to put my food
because there's too many gundams alana
have you ever had
sexual intercourse at least once define
sexual intercourse oh yeah it's so
broken mine's really broken
oh my god what's wrong with you guys oh
no what's happening
no i'm in the i'm in the sky me too wait
a sec
i see you bruce oh my god yeah yeah
jacob i see you in this game oh my god i
see you in this guy
yeah here we come oh this is like iron
man 2.
everyone's favorite you're so close
right black widow where are you
you're so close you're so close i'm
coming to oh there's rockets coming at
me there you are
anti-air how's it going oh my god bruce
what happened to you
i uh i'm looking around and trying to
figure out how to get into this chat
from what i can tell you got the [ __ ]
kicked out of you
oh i definitely here
okay where's the chest i'm gonna heal
over there
you go boss oh my god didn't that didn't
last long
i gotta switch my gear real quick cover
me gotta switch my gear hold on
actually we're in a pretty good spot to
switch gears to be honest yeah i gotta
put my good gear on
level 10. i'm wearing the best gear i
have so
hey guys why am i
buying security is my controller
vibrating am i getting shot yeah
yeah you want to assume i'm not no you
are oh yeah i unlocked my skills real
quick hold on
why is this happening now it's like it
seems like a bad time for you guys to be
here we go
all right skills unlocked all right guys
iron man's in the fight oh it's over
hold on i just got some blue gear hold
on [ __ ] sake
oh yeah now now i see it oh my god
there's a big ass dude too yeah there is
a face
v oh my god he's a tough one i didn't
even
really should be something that you can
toggle like the fact that you have to
spam it
out of the sky what are you doing here
kamala
this is not what i want at all what are
we doing here boss what
what's this can we get up could we not
do this
um mate oh
this is happening here's what happens
when i try to get up oh come on
i'm like a little monkey oh come on come
on you get up there you do it
help i don't know what i got i caught
all right i just did darth maul on him
so that'll do
oh no not again not again for [ __ ]
sake uh
all right we have an objective yeah
let's go towards that shall we
ah turrets on the
turrets on the yeah everything you say
is cut out at the ends turrets are the
watches
what with the turret i forgot that the
hulk was on our team yeah well if you
see him
you'll understand why you forgot that he
was on our team
i'm fighting a big robot oh oh no
oh no that's not good he had a date with
a tree it's all right
it's no it's no matter
there's your little chest cool a
heavyweight spark band
yeah hell yeah that's so cool
did hulk sort of shut up he did we're
proud are you dude
i got some lightweight pin particle with
spencer gauntlet god i love that for you
oh i just heard rahul in the video game
yeah yeah that was weird ralph turned
himself
on discord yeah did he just mute himself
in discord and not in the game
that's not what we wanted i think he did
yeah yeah but we can hear you in the
game
it's really quiet
it's like he's actually in the back of
the plane you know we're just
he's just far away it's true okay so
what do we want to do
we can we can't hum that that's not
that's avengers i've been told many
times
different avengers oh that's so fun
iron man needs help iron man help i am
coming to help
iron man
ah look at look at all this ads tiny
look at how tiny black widow is compared
to
everybody else yeah you're right real
small
okay i just want to go towards this
question mark you see you seeing me is
the 65
yeah right behind you guys yeah there is
a chest over here
can hulk make boxing gloves out of a car
like in the movie
man i love which i love that i [ __ ]
love that
how to get to how to such a good movie
where to
i'll do my laser spin drop kick that
dude all right oh my god
laser spin okay beard yeah
yeah hello black widow hey rahul and
this in this uh avengers
you know black widow and hulk may fall
in love
wait who's black widow i am
oh all right i'm gonna fly at walking
speeds like you following
you wanted you and jacob sure he wanted
jacob yeah
elite teams oh
titanfall yeah just stand in it and then
hold x
oh it glitches all over the place when
you use it fall out
are you ready yeah dude i'm doing that
ready ultimate team up
to fight that big robot it looks like
you guys oh
how long is the whole get oh that's nice
one of their agents
why is the camera spinning around in
circles why
is this the thing i'm trying to fight
that you've decided to do cameron
[Music]
throwing punches at a [ __ ] what's up
frozen games rising game's rising
i was going to say as my friend who
likes tick tock more than any other
friend i bet you're devastated about
this tick tock news
how are you coping game unfortunately
it's gonna be fine tic toc's gonna be
fine it's not gonna go away they're
never gonna ban tick tock i could
promise you that
they're gonna remove post office boxes
but they're never gonna ban tickets
i promise you then where did that come
from
star wars ruins everything let me tell
you
get that chest for a second yes
all right hulk all right you know oh i
gotta change my gear hold on
i think now we can leave probably right
yeah let's get the hell out of here oh
wait there's one more chest
oh wait hold on where up here inside the
window
um i can't break through i gotta find
the way around oh
that doesn't make any sense why do we
need a band why do we need a man
yeah like don't you have guns they're
like no only a green monster will do
oh yeah 50 nano tubes so we can break
all these too
yeah yeah hey uh are we the baddies
this all seems pretty unnecessary i feel
like we might be the bad guys no
remember guys aim is the bad guy aol
instant messenger
yes never forget aol's the bad guy
oops he just [ __ ] everything
all right can't wait for the game to
freeze again elevated oh god not another
elevator
if if hulk attacks anything oh geez
we can't stop him he's frozen he might
have stopped something in my game oh no
he's making particle effects
is he can't tell yeah he's pulling [ __ ]
out of the ground throws it again
oh just don't move
okay just killing [ __ ]
damn lasers i'll take care of these
turrets around the edge of the room here
i missed i miss hard son of a [ __ ] nope
nope that looks bad yeah i think it was
just
get them hulk
nice all i ever see is hulk in my screen
i need to leave whoa this place big whoa
oh god he's gonna attack um i'll break
his shield
which big boy i
yeah oh he's dead he got shot in the
face by black widow
oh the agents just
how long does it take us for all to do a
mission together that was [ __ ]
it took us four hours four hours yeah a
long time a bit of a bit of a time but
we did it we did it
oh my god and now it's frozen again it's
frozen so
well we can rate our experience i'd love
to oh i'm getting the audio glitch
we're all on the same thing still so i
think i can just select a mission and it
should be
yeah go for it i trust you oh my god
god i'm still gonna be hulk just such a
beta
just such a beta not either of you the
gay oh
i was going to say yeah i was like hold
on a minute
i'm good you're correct